trying to get innovative and keep it
fresh and interesting so there's some
range of different things we find
ourselves doing now that we didn't
before
you got your perspective
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
i'm todd capp what um what's been the
biggest challenge and what's been the
biggest opportunity in running something
through the beginning of this year q1
which is always crazy for you because
super bowl
you had a crazy successful super bowl
halftime show this year
and then and then as you're just
probably gearing up for summer which i'm
sure for
soda let's call it what it is big time
territory and then boom this happens so
break that down for me yeah i think it's
crazy when you think of it
2020 you know from a pepsi point of view
we actually started the year really
strong we had just launched our
a new advertising campaign that's what i
like which is our first new tagline in
20 years we had a huge super bowl as you
said big focus on
pepsi zero sugar with our spot the
halftime show with jlo and shakira was
the most talked about you know
we look at this thing for called share a
voice we had i think 43
of all the brand conversations on social
uh were about pepsi during the super
bowl so i mean we
were killing it to start the year and
then all of a sudden covet happens and
you're just like
oh my god and i think um you know when
you look at just kind of the seismic
shift that it takes in culture and just
the world
you know the the rules business of uh
the rules changing
in business and how it all works and so
the first and foremost thing we did is
we wanted to focus on our people
i think like a lot of organizations we
have these front line employees
who are driving you know making moving
and selling our product on a daily basis
keeping grocery stores stocked all that
making sure that they're safe and
protected and so
we spent a lot of time you know
protecting the safety of our 90 000
employees on our front line as well as
you know from a corporate standpoint
you know really doing a lot to provide
protective gear screening services
pepsico foundation meals all that kind
of stuff but the real opportunity as you
talk about it is as a brand standpoint
you know we have an onus as a brand
that's connected to culture and music
and
providing you know enjoyment and
entertainment for folks on how we can
kind of connect with people in an
authentic way
which is really how we started during
that transition period after everyone
got through the shell shock of oh my
gosh this coveted thing is happening
like what the heck is happening
um really trying to figure out how we
could create a shared moment of unity
given people are feeling isolated how we
could raise awareness and do some good
for covid
uh 19 you know relief but also create
this moment of fun and enjoyment which
is really what brought us to this idea
of partnering with a global citizen
who they're a great organization you
know we created this thing with them
called one world together at home which
was this really great
you know thing with them lady gaga the
world health organization we brought
together artists from you know all over
the world to really have the
the first of its kind on all three
networks big kind of concert
relief fun you know thing and you know
we had to
agility you know redirect i you know i
redirected my entire brand team to work
on this other marketing resources worked
with you guys and things oh we know
it was bad [ __ ] crazy but we um you know
we we designed the logo for the thing we
helped with artists outreach built a ton
of marketing materials shifted our media
schedule against it all
in a matter of weeks to just create and
co you know
and todd on that on that note i'm sorry
to interrupt but i want to get a lot in
here before we bounce out
another thing that we haven't touched on
today working from home
have you been surprised disappointed
what's been your observation
on what you thought you could do with
you and your team and your agency
partners and others
and versus the real who did todd kopp
what did todd kops and the man think
going in
and what do you now believe yeah it's
interesting because working from home
like we've always been a um you know
it's somewhat flexible work environment
of pepsico and people you know you have
a snow day you work from home you're
working from the city
a lot of my team's based in new york
city and so they don't want to drive up
to westchester so they'll work from the
city for a day
so we've had all we've had zoom we've
been on zoom for a while
but what was interesting is like people
back when it was there you know no one
would put their screen on they'd always
have a little sticky note covering their
camera you know and they'd just be on
they treat it like a conference call i
think now
because of necessity everyone's really
leaning in and using all the tech
as it's intended and it's actually
working quite well and quite seamlessly
and um you know and it's really nice and
i think todd i literally
never want to be on a conference call
ever again
like one of the reasons i was skeptical
and concerned
is i'm a very touchy feely i like it in
the room you know i remember
the last meeting i was with you i'm like
drawing on my desk you know like
i like that stuff yet
yet this is working big time for me i
feel the humanity through it i just do
and and what for sure i can tell you
right now
i am absolutely not going on a phone
conference call because those
[ __ ] they've never been good for me well
i'll tell you even aside from the um the
efficiency aspect of zoom and all this
stuff
i will tell you from a cultural
standpoint our team has never felt
closer more tight-knit
background of their house the
authenticity it's and
what's what's so fascinating is we have
such a range of people we have people on
our team who are
straight out of college in a studio in
manhattan by themselves and you have
somebody
living in the suburbs with a dog
crawling on them and a spouse on a
conference call and kids asking for
questions on their homework and
you're they're all on this together and
it really just makes people human and
real and brings us authentic
connectivity that we're all
you know i'm gonna say we're all in this
together but no it is one of those
things where
we really are you you feel that
connection which as a team
you really need and you can empathize
with people to actually get more agile
and quicker and faster around a lot of
things you're doing
hey everybody on youtube first of all
thank you so much so humbled for your
time
i don't want to watch but time is the
biggest asset so thank you for watching
that video
if uh if you got some value out of that
there's a plenty more where that came
from
feel free to check it out